hello and welcome to this video i got
white again
i had a black game but my opponent never
moved
it probably counts yeah towards them
let's say color distribution it should
be roughly equal but
anyway we get a grunfeld
[Music]
this way
that's funny i had the same thing just
some games
go
as bishop d5 and sa5
you should d5 is i think the more
precise
[Music]
move
this should be 2 a5
a3 a4 i don't quite remember
and i have to play knight e3 first oh
god it's been a while
since i looked at this a5 i have to play
knight e3 first
and of course it's totally ignored um
okay
let's play e3 then
a5 is is the more
[Music]
commonly seen way to play this position
queen to e6 is that coming or
maybe
i want to be ready against a4 to play b4
that would be
nice from a structural point of view
interesting
yeah where do you go
am i not coming with e4 here it looks
really
weird am i missing something or
it just goes to e6 here right okay
okay now e4 is not possible
sure okay
so
i can just take on d4 here right my
queen is not protected
playing for tricks yeah yeah but you can
do that
i i have um no i have
had knight f4 at the end okay anyway
let's play knight f4 here as well
now 95 maybe
isn't that good for white what's what's
the big idea here
knight e4 or
i thought e4 now where
e4 is also e6
which looks interesting but okay play e4
i mean where is the queen going that's
that's the thing that
that irritates me all the way back
okay e6 there are a couple of tactics
now f takes bishop g7 king g7 rook c7
looks crushing
and what exactly is he doing against it
this one yeah i can take now uh on f7
but
if i just take with the queen on b2
what's what's the move for black i don't
see it
knight f6 or
okay
i don't have anything
decisive here it's very tough to believe
maybe just rook t1
get more pieces into the game
maybe i should play something like h3
knight f6 queen to e5
intending queen to g5 that looks good
actually
that's something that i should maybe do
okay he goes away
without me having to play h3
queen g5 coming
yeah queen g5
or i can take i can take then check on
e6
check on e6 it's also good right
um yeah e5 looks winning
knight g6 also looks winning let's go e5
and i can check now there but this is
also strong
check
and check
okay
so let's have a look there that was
certainly
okay for black and then he killed
himself somehow
it should be too took to take really
long to remember my own theory
a5 you play i think
knight e3 first here okay but
this this is also what he did is a
completely viable
strategy so this
and probably knight h4 is not good
this this
takes takes and this was a scare
but i thought this sorry that this would
work but
the engine actually
evaluates this as perfectly playable
yeah certainly
maybe not a line that you voluntarily go
for with black
because it doesn't feel like you need to
sacrifice something
but um yeah the computer actually thinks
you should do that otherwise you're
worse
and this is indeed leading to a good
position for me
knight e5 should should be a good move
right
yeah now the engine um
also agrees yeah and this is not not
good now i'm just threatening to
take here twice and this
is just good for white e4
where do you go now i mean queen g5
looks terrible
this and then i mean this is hanging but
e6 i thought looks awful
yeah he just has terrible pieces here
particularly the queen
okay this was played at e6 so this is
just
his king position is is falling apart
yeah here h3 knight f6 queen e5 was
probably already
pretty strong but it's it's massively
winning probably with more than one
continuation
so yeah and this is
convincing enough yeah
he went in he went into the maid but
it's completely winning anyway
okay guys thanks for watching